23 ça fait 23 jours qu'elle a été nommé
à matignon est le nom de la première
ministre mme imprime toujours pas et
nous encourageons la parole je veux le
dire avec lisa bernd bohr et c'est pour
ça je crois qu elisabeth board n'ont
rien c'est encore nouvelle tentative ce
matin avec thomas sotto c'est une bonne
nouvelle ou c'est une mesure
électoraliste comment vous recevez cette
info tenu par exemple de bornes hier à
l'est la prochaine fois ce sera la bonne
françois hollande et julie gayet se sont
dit oui en toute discrétion ce samedi à
tulle ou tard à l'isf actuel à 67 ans
l'ancien président de la république se
marier pour la première fois dans sa
région de prédilection la corrèze un
mariage en toute simplicité parmi les
invités le chanteur benjamin biolay un
ami du couple soit ça m'a beaucoup
touché la presse ne dit pas si les
mariés sont arrivés en scooter à la
cérémonie on leur souhaite en tout cas
beaucoup de bonheur le 10
m avec paillettes dans sa vie illuminé
illuminait ça marche 9 fois pour tony
allez vous déguiser tous prêts à fin de
soirée bon c'est sûr que les bas en mode
fashion week et à pied rouge mais quoi
qu'il arrive je vous connais plutôt qu'à
long jeu pouvant décider moraliser le
moment en faisant à celle ci mois
[Applaudissements]
bon ben faut cette vie on n'a pas de
réseaux sociaux on l'abat téléphone en
arrière on est coupé du monde on est
perdu mais quoi qu'il arrive on s'amuse
et ça cette fois-ci balles elles sont
souvent à tulle parce qu'ils ont acheté
une maison là-bas donc un s'installent
là bas elle tue elle arpente le marché
et c'est simplement moi jen non mais
elle va c'est le marché ils ont une
vraie ville donc je t'explique ça doit
te sortir grâce à elle arpente le marché
mais le ballon avec laurent quelle est
la chose la plus impossible que vous
ayez fait dans votre vie à part soutenir
a dit d'aldo
[Rires]
vous faites jamais de blagues sur les
gens
c'est impossible de soutenir hidalgo
mais vous ne l'avez pas le jour où elle
s'est présentée sur son nom 1,7 pour
cent c'est un peu un référendum pro
utilise album est hâtive à paris pour
vous
il allait plus là du tout donc quand
elle sera de passage à paris en voyage
officiel
peut-être que vous l'un vitré et donc le
candidat est la plus
je le paie l'avenir julie gayet harper a
déjà fait maison le syndic est ce que
j'en ai trop qu'ils arpentent le marché
je n'ai rien à petit se marie françoise
il était président il a rien foutu
soit respectueux soit aujourd'hui parce
que c'est parce que toi t'es pas mariés
et un jeune candidat estampillé nu dans
l'aveyron qui a été filmé en train de
sniffer ce qui ressemble à la paix nuit
dicks il s'agit de doliprane écrasé ce
qu'il peut et est-ce qu'il doit rester
votre candidat c'est une vidéo qui t'a
dit à plusieurs années a visiblement une
voie là il est revenu sur cette vidéo
enfin j'ai pas de commentaires à faire
là-dessus je voulais que vous
interveniez sur jean luc mélenchon sur
le refus d'obtempérer mais
malheureusement le temps de parole
j'allais dire m'oblige à ne pas vous
laisser parler maintenant puisque nous
avons dépassé le temps de parole avec
les républicains c'est monsieur boddaert
qui me fait passer cette information
donc je me soumets généralement à la
réglementation et je suis obligé obligé
et je le regrette croyez bien de ne pas
continuer cette conversation qui était
passionnante y voit là il prend un peu
de poudre il a dit il s'est expliqué il
a dit que c'était du doliprane écrasé
oui alors mais oui d'eau mais les gens
sont vilains caen va déjà les rumeurs
partent vite comme ça et 5 depuis le
début benoît magimel personnes pensent
que c'est juste un migraineux et avec
cette marge de 10% ça me semble
important de bien faire comprendre
je compris mais je dis que vous aviez bu
la parole en revanche je vois que vous
avez racheté les vestes de valérie
pécresse durant la campagne électorale
veste rouge
qu'elle avait pour renflouer les caisses
des républicains y avait peut-être des
ventes sur ebay qu'est ce que c'est et
je hais je vous félicite pour ce beau
geste pour valérie pécresse que vous
avez fait et c'est là qu'on se dit à
l'époque benjamin griveaux il n'avait
pas été très critique en tirait la vidéo
et son kiki il aurait immédiatement de
dire que c'était juste parce qu'il était
en train de faire une télé consultation
il son urologue donc évidemment pas de
souci là dessous alors évidemment pour
rassurer tout le monde là cet homme a
pris du doliprane cela dit ça m'inquiète
comment il fait avec des suppositoires
merci quel âne merci mathieu merci julie
félicitations suchard julie j'avais un
bouquet pour vous voilà vous n'avez
vous embrasse ma demande il
n'y a pas de lien on a vérifié
[Rires]